how serious is the situation there right
now it certainly is quite serious but I
would not say that it's as serious as it
was in 2010 when North Korea fired a
barrage of shells at us frontline South
Korean island which killed two Marines
in two civilians also about three years
ago in 2013 when after North Korea
conducted his third nuclear test North
carrots soldiers on what he called in a
state of war back then nothing really no
military armed clash happened after that
declaration so it is certainly serious
right now but this might just be a step
toward tensions being lowered somehow if
the the governments of the two Koreas
are able to find a way out of the
detentions some North Korea always has a
game plan what are they trying to
achieve by upping tensions right now
first they are quite irritated by the
fact that South Korea has resumed its
propaganda broadcasts in the
demilitarized zone for the first time
since 2004 those propaganda broadcasts
are basically blare the loudspeakers
blare a lot of propaganda that are very
critical of the Kim jong-un regime the
leader himself the way North Koreans
live so they are quite irritated that by
the fact that this could actually affect
the the mindsets of the North Korean
troops guarding the DMZ and it
undermines the fighting power the war
fighting capabilities of the North
Korean troops in the border in the
border areas and also it under undercuts
the the base for the Kim jong-un's power
and in the regime